speaking of another player that bounced
back with back-to-back victories after a
loss in the first round in the fourth
round the first round of today's Wesley
so with us Wesley I want to talk to you
about this game thanks for having me in
the fifth round against Sam Shanklin
because yeah this was very very
interesting yeah sacrifice E5 did you
expect this oh well I was actually
following Hikaru nakamura's game like
it's a good lead he was getting a good
position and you were getting good
position as well yeah like I just looked
at the board at his board on the table
and I noticed that we have the exact
same position after A6 in fact just
before very quickly without thinking but
uh action determined
is that technically cheating
[Laughter]
but no I mean in the Olympics five years
ago actually Sam and I have the exact
same position until moved when against
the Chinese guys in the last round so
but in this tournament I've been
analyzing with Gary and Hikaru so we
tend to get similar positions
tell you that experience has been for
you well it's great I
I it's a great honor and privilege to
analyze with the living legend Gary
Kasparov and just to feed the way that
his insights the way his mind works and
then the way he looks at and thinks of
certain positions he's still very sharp
and you know he's got a lot of
experience he knows his principles well
so very good was I should have done it
much sooner because previous years he
was always working with Peter Peter
Fiddler yes thank God but uh yeah I mean
he's still sharp he's playing very good
chess so it's uh incredible but did that
inspire you yesterday we actually named
an opening Gambit after you that B5 move
followed by Bishop E5 that gave you the
13 move Victory oh it's Jeffrey yeah but
that was uh was that a nice game
uh influence at all
no uh not not that time but uh but
pretty much everywhere else yeah yeah
not that time but still I I think uh and
you learn a lot from analyzing with Gary
absolutely let's talk about this game so
E5 an interesting Pawn sacrifice and we
got to this position how did you assess
it by the way
well at this point I thought Sam played
very well I thought E5 was very good in
mode 5. because otherwise again combine
but I thought they should take with the
queen on move eight maybe because uh
the idea is that Queen takes and then
once the Queens are exchanged ideas that
you move the
okay Knight takes the idea to remove the
bishop light squared Bishop real quickly
and he castles long
so and then he gets really fast
development so I thought if I was a
brilliant move but yes I was very
surprised when it took me the Knight
because now I get to pin him
and uh it's not so easy there's this
funny moment when he actually could have
Castle along at the end yeah I mean he
should have done this yeah clearly and
then black has the
initiative but maybe he didn't even
consider this he just didn't he just
didn't perhaps he didn't yeah I I would
be surprised if he did because it's uh
hard to move but here yeah Castle yeah I
think he made some mistakes like this
this seems to happen yeah yeah I thought
I was thinking slower mode here but I
have to go for it because when when else
am I going like I have to attack and
you sensed at that moment you timed it
perfectly with this move F5 yeah so okay
ethics was actually a mistake yeah yeah
it seems to have uh won the game not
Rook G3 okay E3 yeah Rook E3 that's key
move uh Queen H5 broke H3
and what about Queen G5 maybe four games
attempt to Simply Knight before yeah
everything comes with Tempo yeah somehow
there have been many myths so many
mistakes in this tournament I think also
the short time control but here he
played 95 very quickly Bishop E2 was
okay for black
Bishop takes E2 I was gonna play Rook up
seven then he takes
frog makes a draw
but 95 was a blunder after that why it's
just completely winning he probably
missed this move Queen to D2
is that how you feel about it yeah
probably he just saw
you cannot you can Fork a queen in a
rook and he just went for it without
thinking and if you go Queen to D4
perhaps Queen to G7 now yeah E2 I have
to protect that uh Pawn Yeah so uh yeah
I gotta make the door but the queen
Little Queen G7 Rook F7 I guess instead
of Queen G6 on move 24
I guess
25 and the position is still extremely
difficult right after Rook F3 there's a
lot of checkmates coming along yeah for
sure but black could defend but I feel
generally determined players are
including me are making tons of mistakes
game against Savion was very weird like
I thought I had a very bad position
after move two move three
the
much much much better after after two
days going in the final day you probably
start understanding what's going right
what's going wrong what are the
adjustments that you're going to make
going into the final day to to make that
push
well if I want to fight for first place
I gotta start winning games after game
because uh I mean I had a very slow
start and then
so and you know level one is playing
very well
so I'm gonna have to
you know we win a lot of games and try
to take risks and
try to uh try to attack that's uh that's
the thing but um
I I think I feel in this tournament it
feels like there's always a different
winner every single year like now the
one is winning linear one one year
so uh it's uh it's interesting I'm still
not clear how the best way is to prepare
for chess 960
uh
but but I guess you just gotta show up
sharp and you gotta have good time mad
time management but I still look very
much too
forward to analyzing it with Gary
tomorrow and whatever happens happens
you know this is the storm it's a
showdown after all it's uh more of an
exhibition but
I guess a player you wanna you wanna we
wanna yeah you got you gotta win at some
point I've been playing this tournament
for for this thing with my Fortress well
you did win a world championship in
chess 960 so you definitely have a lot
of experience in this uh format yeah
time control was slightly long longer at
that point but
yeah it Wesley will let you get some
rest go get ready for tomorrow we'll see
you tomorrow yeah thank you Christian